Welcome back for more cosmology on a rainy day.
Uh,
you'll recall,
uh,
maybe what we were trying to do.
Uh,
we're trying to determine the past and future of the universe,
which it turns out can be summarized by a single number,
namely the scale factor of the universe.
Um,
it's actually not a,
it's not a single number.
It's actually a function,
right?
It's a function of time.
The scale factor changes with time.
And so when I make this grandiose statement that I'm going to talk about the
past and future of the universe,
what I really mean is I want to determine what the scale factor is as a function
of time.
And so that's just a,
a standard kind of a graph.
Here's the scale factor.
Usually give them the letter,
a function of t,
here's time.
Uh,
the present is somewhere,
uh,
along this graph.
Call that now,
uh,
and so here's,
and the universe has some scale factor at the present time.
And what we're going to do is we're going to call that,
define the scale factor at the present time to be one.
There's,
we're just gonna that's called normalizing when you set a,
when you multiply something by some convenient number so that it comes out to be
one at a convenient moment.
So that's just the definition.
We define the current scale factor to be one,
it'd be unity.
And so there's a point here,
uh,
right now,
the scale factor is what we also know what the slope of the scale factor is
because we measure that from the Hubble constant.
Uh,
and so in an appropriate set of units,
the scale factor is increasing at a rate of,
uh,
the Hubble constant,
which is I think two times 10 to the minus 18,
uh,
per second.
So if the scale factor is one right now,
then one second from now,
the scale factor is going to be one plus two times 10 to the minus 18.
So every second it gets two times 10 to the minus 18 bigger.
Uh,
that's not a real large increase.
And in fact,
over,
uh,
over the entire history of humanity,
it won't,
it won't increase by that much.
Let's see,
in a,
in a million years,
uh,
there are something like,
okay,
Ian,
a 10 to this six years,
there are three times 10 to the seven times 10 to the six seconds.
That's three times 10 to the 13 seconds.
Multiply that by two times 10 to the minus 18.
Uh,
and the scale factor,
uh,
increases,
by three times 10 to the 13 times two times 10 to the minus 18.
Uh,
that's six times 10 to the minus five.
So it still hasn't made a whole lot of difference even in a million years from
now.
Uh,
but uh,
keep at it for awhile and the scale factor is going to pile up,
uh,
and will increase.
So we know that it's increasing.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
the question is,
is this increased changing with time?
So let's see.
This is,
if it doesn't change,
if it's just a straight linear increase,
this is the situation in which there's no matter in the universe.
So the universe is not slowing down because of gravity because there's no matter
in it.
And that gets labeled with this factor.
All Mugu being equal to zero.
Let me remind you.
Uh,
Omega is defined as the density of the universe divided by the critical density.
The critical density is how dented has to be to turn around.
So,
uh,
another possible track for the universe.
We know it's expanding at a particular rate now,
but it could slow down in the future.
Turner out of fallback could look something like this.
This is the case where Omega is greater than one.
Okay.
And then the intermediate case where Omega is less than one but not equal to
zero,
it sort of does this,
it falls off a little bit,
continues to expand something like that.
And this is Omega less than one,
but still greater than zero.
Yeah.
Okay.
So here's the goal.
We got to figure out which track we're on at the moment.
We sit here,
uh,
and we measured the Hubble constant.
So all we know is where we are and where we're going in the short run.
And what we want to do is to figure out which of these possibilities the
universe is actually following.
And in so doing,
decide whether we're going to end up falling back together.
In this big crunch or expanding forever.
And we talked a little bit last time about a kind of direct way of determining
this,
namely,
uh,
measuring all MCHA.
This omika factor is the density of the universe divided by the critical
density.
You could in principle,
go out and measure the density of the universe.
Uh,
you could,
you can compute the critical density.
You divide one by another and you know,
uh,
which of these possibilities turns out to be true and that ran into trouble,
as you'll recall.
So a direct measurement
of all Monica,
this leads to trouble in the form of dark matter.
So the universe turns out to be full of this dark matter.
Uh,
if you add up all the galaxies,
the mass of all the galaxies,
including dark matter.
So Mass Yen,
galaxies,
uh,
gives you an Omega that's less than one that's around a third or a quarter.
Uh,
but there might be,
you know,
now that we've already discovered that the vast majority of matter is something
we know nothing about,
there might be more of it,
uh,
between galaxies that we don't know about.
So,
uh,
we want a different approach.
So here's something you can do
that,
that's really quite,
quite a different approach to this problem.
Let's,
let's draw that plot up again.
Uh,
and so here's now and then there are these various possibilities,
uh,
and it might go like this
or it might
fall all the way back down like that.
Uh,
so,
uh,
here's something you can do.
Remember that you can look back into the past.
You can look into the past by looking at very distant things and you see the
light coming to you from the time in the past.
So you look,
uh,
into the past because of the light travel time.
And so if,
if now is here,
uh,
we can actually look at objects,
which,
uh,
were existing at some time in the past back say here,
I don't know,
uh,
by looking at things that are 3 billion light years away or something like that.
And the question is,
if you can do that,
uh,
you can figure out how far in the past it is.
By the way,
that's easy.
Measure a distance,
uh,
and time in the past is just distance,
miles per hour,
which way up is it going to be a divided by the speed of light.
So if you can measure the distance to something,
you know,
how long ago,
how far,
how far in the past it was.
So that tells you where it is on this axis.
So then all you need to do is measure the scale factor right
factor at that time.
Then you could see that if you could do this,
you would be able to determine whether at some point in the past you are here,
uh,
if the scale factor was low or here or here.
And therefore,
uh,
if you made accurate measurements of the scale factor in the past,
you could figure out which one of these tracks you're on.
And if you could figure that out,
then you can infer,
uh,
if that track continues,
without,
uh,
some other form of physics kicking in,
you could figure out that it will,
where it will go in the,
so you've got to be able to determine what the scale factor was,
which doesn't seem like,
uh,
it's actually all that easy.
Uh,
but it turns out that this can be done.
And a way to think about this is you have to think about the red shift,
the cosmological red shift in different terms from what we've been thinking
about it so far.
So a different
view of red shift.
You remember,
this is where we started,
right?
We measured the distance to things.
We measure their velocity,
we got Hubble's law,
therefore the universe is expanding.
And the W as we were doing that,
we had the idea that the red shift is telling you something about velocity.
So a red shift.
So,
so one view
is that the red shift
okay.
Tells you something about velocity,
uh,
and the velocities are all moving away from us and therefore the universe is
expanding.
But you'll remember that,
um,
that the cosmological red shift caused by the expansion of the universe,
uh,
that velocity is a little different in kind from the way we ordinary think of
velocity.
It's not,
objects are not moving through space.
Uh,
it's just the space itself is expanding and that leads to some differences.
For example,
in principle,
uh,
the cosmological red shift can cause things that look like the velocity is
potentially greater than the speed of light and things like that.
Uh,
so the cosmological redshift is,
uh,
not the same as an ordinary velocity.
Yeah.
And one way to think about,
uh,
what the red shift is,
is the fall.
So another view,
the universe is expanding.
Uh,
but a lot of the things in the universe are not expanding.
Your not expanding the galaxies not expanding.
And we talked about this a little.
That's because there are forces holding it together.
The earth isn't expanding cause its gravitational force holds it together.
Uh,
I'm not expanding because the chemical bonds between the atoms in my body hold
it together.
The galaxy is not expanding because gravity holds it together.
Um,
but a wavelength of light doesn't have such a force to hold it together.
So as the universe expands,
wavelengths of light,
expand along with it.
Uh,
so this is another view of where the red shift comes from.
that wavelength
of light
expand along with the universe.
That's an interesting thought.
Uh,
so rather than fit.
So the question is why do we observe light from distant galaxies to be red
shifted?
Uh,
in this interpretation?
It's not because these things are moving away from us.
It's because during the time between when that wavelength was emitted and when
we see it,
the universe has expanded and the wavelength has expanded along with it,
and therefore we see a longer wavelength than we would have,
uh,
from,
a photon that hadn't been traveling as long because the universe in that case
wouldn't have traveled,
wouldn't have expanded as much,
uh,
wavelengths of light expand along with the universe.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
when we observe,
distant objects,
okay,
the wavelength we observe is longer
then when it was emitted
because the universe has been expanding during that time.
This is,
yes,
go ahead.
So if the universe is expanding as wide as troubling to us,
it reaches us.
Universe will be somewhat larger than when then when the light was admitted.
So is the time,
is the time that we calculate shipping in the past?
Is that the distance divided by,
is that the original distance divided by two light or,
okay,
so there's the really,
this is this complicated thing about what do we mean by distance in an expanding
universe.
Uh,
and what you mean?
This is a good question.
What you mean by distance is how much it,
okay.
So the first thing to say is that cosmologists worry about this a lot and there
are different kinds of distances that can be defined.
There's the coordinate distance,
which doesn't change as the universe expands or other kinds of distances in the
particular case of what we're doing right now.
Uh,
the key way you measure distance remembers the standard candle.
So you'd define what's called the luminosity distance,
which is how much fainter something looks.
And so basically distances defined.
Uh,
so let me,
this is kind of a parentheses.
What do I mean by distance?
Distance is defined by this equation.
So what do you mean by distance in this case is how much fainter or the object
you're looking at,
uh,
then,
then otherwise,
uh,
and so something that's twice as far away,
what does that mean for something to be twice as far away?
It means the light from a standard candle is four times fainter.
And so you'd define distance as,
uh,
the dimming of light because that's the way you measured the thing.
And then you have to be careful when you're doing this out in,
in,
in strict terms,
you have to be careful that,
that,
that kind,
that the way you've defined,
you don't get confused about which kind of distance you're you're working on.
Uh,
so that defines distance.
Then time,
the look back time,
it turns out to be a more or less,
uh,
certainly for short distances,
correctly defined as distance oversee.
Uh,
but you do have to worry about this when you get into large cosmological
distances and a,
I don't want to go into that,
but the different kinds of distances are related to each other in complicated
ways.
Uh,
okay.
So this is how you,
this is,
uh,
basically back to the question of how you get the x axis on that graph.
Uh,
I'm now talking about the y axis,
the scale factor.
So then you want to,
how do you measure the scale factor,
the scale factor.
So the scale factor now of the universe now divided by the scale factor,
then when you emitted that wavelength is going to be equal to the observed
wavelength divided by the wavelength of the light when it was emitted,
because that's how much larger the universe has gotten and the wavelengths have
gotten big along with it.
So that's equal to,
uh,
met Plus Delta Lambda as we've defined it before,
over lamb to emit it,
which is equal to one plus xe is the red shift.
Z remember,
is the change in the wavelength divided by the wavelength and when it was
emitted?
So by measuring red shift,
you can tell what the scale of the universe was relative to the scale of the
universe.
Now,
uh,
when that light was emitted,
now remember,
I defined the scale factor now to be one.
So that means one over a is equal to one plus the Z or the scale factor of the
universe in units where it's currently equal to one is equal to one over one
plus xe.
Yeah.
And Z.
You measure.
Okay.
And so,
uh,
in principle you can measure both,
both axes of that graph.
And so if I now go back to that,
to my plot,
you could measure some points on this plot.
Now all of them are in the past,
not the future because you can't,
uh,
you can't look into the future by this light travel time trick.
But you could go out there and you could discover a,
if you made really excellent measurements,
you could discover that there's a point right here that have particular a galaxy
or whatever it is you're looking at is,
is far away such that the time back is this.
And then you measure the red shift,
you get a scale factor.
Uh,
and you could measure,
uh,
that,
at that time the universe had such and such a scale factor.
And if you measured a whole bunch of these things and they sort of wind up in
this nice way,
uh,
then you might conclude,
well,
uh,
the universe is doing this and you might then extrapolate to determine what the
universe is going to do in the future.
Uh,
and so this is just the huddle diagram interpreted in a slightly different way,
uh,
and uh,
being looked at at a distance sufficiently far away that the rate of expansion,
uh,
would have been different back then than it is now.
So,
uh,
I'm going to draw it all again.
Here's a,
here's t,
there's this,
uh,
here's one of these.
Uh,
and here's this.
But you know,
that's not usually how we plot the huddle diagram.
What we're usually plotting,
as you'll recall,
is distance versus philosophy,
because those are the things we actually measure.
Velocity is red shift Z.
And remember that,
uh,
one over one plus z equals a,
um,
or let's see,
one over a,
a one plus Xe,
uh,
a overlay,
one over one minus a over a,
yeah,
one minus a over a equals z.
So this represents the scale factor.
This access,
whereas this,
uh,
what we actually usually plot is m minus M,
which you'll recall is equal to five log d over 10 parsecs.
Uh,
and so this scale represent time because distance can be converted to time
because we know the speed of light.
So this is a time axis in really weird unit and this is a scale factor access in
really weird unit.
Okay.
But you can therefore transform each of these lines,
which is scale factor versus time into an equivalent line on this plot.
Uh,
so the Green Line is the plot where where the universe just expand,
uh,
and there's no mass,
nothing slows down.
So it kind of looks like this.
All right.
Now
what are the points?
This is now and uh,
in,
uh,
in the time factor.
And then up here is then,
okay,
so you're going from now to then,
so you're of sitting on this point,
looking back this way.
Uh,
and here is scale factor eight equals one.
And here's scale factor.
A equal small.
Okay.
Cause the Z is getting bigger,
therefore is getting smaller.
So what would the red curve look like on this plot of the things we actually
measure?
Well,
when it's close,
the red curve sits right on top of the green curve.
So it kind of starts out like this.
No,
there's no distinction.
Then at a certain point in the past,
let's see.
Um,
what do I want?
How do I want to do this?
Uh,
let's pick a particular time.
So that's a particular distance.
Uh,
at that time,
the scale factor is smaller on the red curve than it is on the green curve.
If the scale factor is smaller,
the red shift has to be bigger.
So what's gonna be happening here is that the red line is going to gradually
diverged from the Green Line and just the same way it does here in such a way
that attic given distance,
that is to say,
given time in the past,
the red shift is bigger,
which means the scale factor is small.
And then the brown curve,
what kind of do the same thing?
Only more.
So
though,
this is what we expect to see.
This is Omega Greater Than One,
uh,
Omega less than one,
but still greater than zero.
Omega equal to zero,
so all the Hubble dot grants we've looked at so far have been down at this end
here where they're all lying on top of each other.
But you can imagine that if you get out to big redshifts redshift of one at a
retrofit of one,
the scale factor is half of what it is today.
You're halfway back to the big,
to the big bang.
In terms of scale factor,
you could imagine that these things would really look quite different as indeed
they do.
In this little plot I've drawn when the scale factor is half of what it is
today,
if the scale factors 1% less than it is today,
you'll have a tough time telling these things apart.
So what do you need to do?
What you want to do is measure redshifts in distances,
plop them on this plot and see which of these lines turns out to be true.
What do you need to do that what you need is a really bright standard candle.
Why does it need to be bright?
Because you need to be able to see it at large
distances.
Uh,
and the thing that happened in the 1990s and that has transformed cosmology is
that we are now able to make these kinds of measurements all the way out to a
red shift of one and some cases further.
And the particular standard candle we're looking at are you so called type one a
supernovae.
Uh,
I'll discuss what these are later on,
but for the moment,
let's just,
uh,
let's just take the point that their standard candles,
therefore we know how bright they are and they're really,
really bright,
uh,
absolute magnitude of something like minus 19.
Uh,
so they're as bright as whole galaxies.
In fact,
they often out shine the galaxy they're in.
These are exploding stars.
And as I say,
we'll talk about the details of exactly how these things work later on.
So type one a Supernova,
turn out to be these really bright standard candles and you can make this kind
of measurement on the,
uh,
I have the data here.
Uh,
but,
uh,
I have to talk about one more technical thing about the way the data's
presented.
Um,
let's see.
Ordinarily the way you tend to plot these things,
as I said,
as you plot red shift versus a apps parent minus absolute magnitude,
this is a quantity known as the distance modulars and it's related to distance,
uh,
by the equation we had before.
Uh,
and so then what you get is you get this and you get this and you get this,
uh,
as,
as we've written it down before.
And the problem is,
uh,
that,
it's hard to tell the differences between these lines because the,
uh,
this is now being measured in magnitude these separation out here to red shift
of one.
Uh,
this is about,
uh,
this interval here in magnitude.
Let me write it that way,
is about,
oh,
I don't know,
a third of a magnitude or something like that.
But this whole plot is,
you know,
if you go all the way back to time zero,
this whole plot is,
I dunno,
uh,
can be 10 to 20 magnitudes.
And so it's just kinda hard to see these little differences between the thing.
So they plot it differently.
Uh,
so that you can bring out these slight differences.
And what they do is they do this,
they plot a quantity called Delta m minus Sam.
What's that?
That's the difference.
Okay.
Between the measured,
uh,
distance modulars and the distance modulates that you would expect,
at that particular red shift in an empty universe.
So m minus M in at a given red shift in an empty universe.
So what does the green curve look like?
The green curve is Omega Equals Zero.
That is to say an empty universe.
Yes.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's just a,
it's just a straight line at zero because it's always true that the empty
universe minus what you expect for the Empty Universe is zero.
So what you've done basically is you've taken this plot and tipped it 45 degrees
so that,
uh,
this,
this Green Line is straight at zero.
And then the brown line,
uh,
will look like this.
Uh,
sorry.
The red line will look like this.
Uh,
the brown line will look like this.
This again,
oh my God.
Greater than one.
Oh my God.
Less than one.
Oh zero.
Yeah.
So that's just convenient because then you can have your scale here.
Go from I dunno,
uh,
minus oh 0.3 to plus 0.3 or something like this.
Uh,
and uh,
uh,
and so you can see the uh,
the whole thing.
Actually I've got the signs wrong,
have an eye,
uh,
because bright things are minus.
So let's just put it as bright.
Okay.
And Faint.
So we've done our very best to confuse you,
right?
First of all,
we started out with a magnitude system that's upside down and logarithmic.
Second of all,
we took the intuitively simple plot of a scale factor versus time,
which actually tells you what you need to know about the universe.
Is it getting bigger?
Is it getting smaller?
Is it going to have a big crunch?
And we transformed it into this rather stranger thing where the things we are
plotting or the things we measure,
but it's not at all obvious how this translates into what the universe is doing.
Then not content with that.
We take that whole thing and subtract something you don't understand from it.
Uh,
so as to flatten out one of the lines.
Okay,
so it's a three part exercise in confusion.
Uh,
and I would say that the number one conceptually difficult thing in this entire
course is to understand how this plot relates to this plot and more difficultly
how this plot relates back to the scale of the universe plot.
Uh,
and that,
uh,
if you can understand that you can understand 21st century cosmology.
Uh,
and so we will work on this a little bit.
So if you're not quite getting it yet,
don't,
don't freak out.
Ah,
you'll have plenty more opportunities to discuss it,
I assure you.
Uh,
in any case,
uh,
even if you're a little puzzled at the moment,
let's look at this plot because this is how the data show up.
So there's an Omega equals zero line,
which is straight,
and then lines below it are increasingly large values of Omega.
And so if you go out and measure a bunch of point a,
you expect to see them kind of lying in a straight line here.
And then you expect to see them falling below that straight line.
And depending on how far below the straight line they fall,
you can determine whether the universe is going to re collapse or not.
So if they end up,
you know,
down here it's going to re collapse.
If they end up here,
it's going to expand forever.
Okay.
How are we doing?
Ready for some data?
Okay.
So,
uh,
in the 1990s,
as I mentioned,
uh,
they actually made this measurement.
In fact,
two different groups made the measurement and they were rivals.
They did things slightly differently.
They are measuring the same kinds of objects.
Here's what they found.
Okay?
So let's see.
This is this Delta and minus m.
So zero on this plot is the empty universe.
Uh,
and then this dotted line is omega.
so let me,
let me a color code.
This the way I had color coded,
uh,
everything earlier.
So I'm gonna,
I'm gonna just take this in.
Uh,
draw the relevant line.
So here's,
here's the Green Line at exactly a Omega equals zero.
And then this thing is the brown line.
Oh,
sorry.
The red line.
You got to get my color straight.
Red Line.
This is Omega less than one.
In fact,
this particular line is for Omega equals a quarter.
And then the brown line is this thing here,
which is oma get equal to one.
So if you fall below the Brown line,
uh,
the university is gonna re is going to really collapse.
Um,
and uh,
right.
What else do I want to do?
I want to say about that.
Nothing because I've now put some points on there.
Yes.
Why are they lying?
Stop in that graph.
Whereas the ones that you drew before they were curved.
Oh,
okay.
Uh,
these are,
these are actually curved.
It's just,
it's just I exaggerated the curvature.
Uh,
the reason that it comes out less curved on this is it's only going up to a
retrofit of what if you continue this out much further,
the curvature would become more obvious.
Uh,
but these are not in fact straight line.
The green one's a straight line because it's just it and everything equals zero.
But there is curvature on these lines.
Okay?
So the problem is obvious.
Here are the observed points and they don't go through any of these lines.
Uh,
and you can,
first of all,
okay,
so there are many things to say about this.
First,
uh,
the error bars.
Let's talk about the error budge.
Rhett shifts are relatively easy to observe.
You can do that to high to high accuracy.
Uh,
this distance modulates is more complicated.
There are two kinds of errors incorporated into these error bars.
Uh,
one is measurement,
okay.
Uh,
errors.
That is to say,
how accurately can you actually measure the brightness of these things?
That's an error in little amp.
You know,
how,
how bro,
how accurately can you measure these things?
They're pretty fate by the time they're out at a red shift of 0.6.
But the other is how good is standard candle?
Is it,
how well do you know exactly what,
uh,
what the absolute magnitude is supposed to be?
So,
uh,
accuracy,
of the standard candle.
And that's an error you'd big amp because you don't know these things turn out
to have a little bit of a spread and brightness and your don't know that.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
that's why the nearby ones,
these ones down on this end,
which you can measure really quite precisely,
still have substantial errors because you don't know how bright the standard
candle is supposed to be,
uh,
to,
to perfect precision.
And so you can see that down below or redshift of 0.2 down in this region here,
you're going to have a really tough time telling the difference between these
lines because the lines are separated by a tiny fraction of a magnitude.
And the errors on these things,
on any individual object is several tenths of a magnitude.
So,
you know,
pretty much pretty much all of these points go through all of the lines.
And so that isn't going to tell you a great deal by the time you're out in here,
you're starting to get several tenths of a magnitude difference in the
prediction.
Now the errors are still several tenths of a magnitude.
So observing one such object isn't going to tell you anything.
Uh,
because supposing I observe any one of these things,
I don't care.
Here's an error bar.
Uh,
and while it doesn't go through this line,
that's only a,
you know,
two times the error.
Uh,
two sigma error for those of you who have studied statistics isn't such a crazy
thing.
Uh,
and so one of these points would not tell you all that much,
but on this plot,
uh,
which was published in 2003 and contains data up until about 2001,
there are a couple dozen points.
Now this line here,
the red line with Omega equals a forth.
We already know that Omega has to be equal to at least a quarter,
cause we've measured all that dark matter out there and we added it up and it
comes out to about Omega equals a quarter or a third or something like that.
Uh,
and so if there's nothing,
nothing else in the universe beyond what we already know about,
you expect it to be on this line.
If there is matter in the universe that we don't know about,
you expect it to be below that line.
So if you take the point at red shift greater than a Ha,
then point to the interesting fact is all of them lie above this line and none
of them lie below that line.
Uh,
now each of them has a different era,
but nevertheless,
the points there are all above the line.
So if it universe truly,
we're following this red line here,
then,
uh,
what would you say?
You would say that half of them should lie above and half of them point should
lie above,
below,
just by random chance.
Um,
so this is throwing,
throwing two dozen coins and having them all come up heads because they've all
by random chance.
If the universe is following this line,
landed above the line.
So you can figure out what the probability of that is.
It's,
you know,
if they're 20 points and they're all heads,
uh,
that's two to the 20th.
That's about one part,
a probability of one in a million.
Uh,
there was another team doing the same experiment.
They measured about the same number of points,
you got the same result.
Uh,
so that's two incidences of a one in a bit,
in a million chance,
that's one in a trillion.
So random errors are not going to get you back down onto the red line,
much less there.
Now look at the Green Line.
This is an empty universe.
Nothing in it at all for ha.
Maybe we're just totally wrong.
If we've screwed up all the dark energy,
all the dark matter,
uh,
and we've got only two points below that that's almost equally improbable.
And so what we think is going on is that this line actually goes above the Green
Line.
And the one current hypothesis for what such a line should be is this solid line
up here.
Uh,
which nicely goes through the point in such a way that kind of half of them are
above and half of them are below the way points ought to be.
Um,
so this is quite strong evidence that in fact,
what the universe is doing is not going below that line,
but going above it.
So what does that tell us?
All right,
let's do this whole exercise backwards.
Delta and minus M versus Z.
Here's the empty universe.
Uh,
and here's what we see,
right?
So how does that go onto the next plot?
This is now a m minus M versus red shift.
Again,
here's the empty universe.
Uh,
and so what appears to be happening is this.
How does that then map onto the scale factor versus the red shift?
Uh,
oh,
it was scale factor versus time.
Sorry,
years.
Now
here's one.
Here's this.
This is now still the empty universe.
It's a straight line in this case.
Uh,
and so what is happening here?
If you go back and you look at a particular distance,
that is to say a particular time ago.
So you're looking here,
uh,
the purple line here has a s has a red shift that is smaller and therefore the
scale factor is large.
So you ought to be here,
right?
So that's what we're observing the implication of,
which is that the future,
it's going to look like this.
Okay,
so the universe in this is universe is expanding.
We already knew that.
Yeah.
And the expansion,
yeah.
Is accelerated.
So something is pushing the universe outworked.
So we had a thought all along,
what's going to happen?
Gravity is gonna pull it back together again.
It's going to be slowing up,
slowing down,
no,
not true.
The universe,
uh,
is being pushed outward
by some kind of force by some kind of energy,
uh,
which has re the,
the characteristics of a repulsive gravity.
So it's anti gravity if you like.
This is what the science fiction writers would certainly call it.
It's something that pushes things away from each other.
Uh,
and this pervades the universe in such a way that it did.
It actually dominates the behavior of the university as a whole.
Uh,
we give this the name dark energy.
Yeah.
And we have absolutely no idea what it is.
Uh,
and uh,
but of course as as my colleague Charlie Ball,
he likes to point out,
uh,
we never,
we never actually admit to people that we don't know what we're talking about.
Uh,
so you,
you,
you observe this kind of thing.
You don't say,
we have no idea what's going on in the universe.
Know you save.
We discovered dark energy,
big triumph,
uh,
and uh,
and so we have discovered dark energy.
And furthermore,
we know something about how much of it there is namely,
uh,
because we can actually measure this curve.
And so you can ask what is the density?
Yeah.
Of the dark energy.
Okay.
Compared to matter.
No.
Uh,
you know how to compare energy to matter,
right?
You have to use e equals MC squared.
So,
uh,
if you have,
energy,
uh,
some amount of energy per meter cubed,
you that can transform that into a energy oversee squared per meter cube.
And that now is in the same units of,
uh,
as a matter density.
Uh,
and so you can have Omeka of the matter,
which we think is about a third or a or something like that.
Uh,
and,
uh,
you can ask how much energy is there?
You can ask how much Omega is there an energy in this dark energy?
Not photons,
not ordinary kinds of energy,
but,
but this repulsive,
mysterious,
repulsive dark energy.
It about three times the amount of matter,
uh,
where all Mugu remember is equal to density over the critical density.
And you know,
it doesn't matter whether it's an energy density divided by c squared or some,
some amount of matter.
Okay?
That's what we think the universe consists of.
So here is the famous pie chart of the universe,
which tells you what's going on.
So you know how pie charts work.
You start with a circle,
okay?
Not to everything.
Uh,
and here's us.
so this is all ordinary matter
and all ordinary kinds of energy,
photons,
what have you,
that we know about,
uh,
and it's something like 4% of the universe.
Then there's a big chunk that's dark matter
and that we discussed last time.
But dark matter is this,
uh,
stuff we can't see.
It might be wimps,
it might be machos.
We don't know.
We can't see it.
But,
uh,
we know it's there.
Why do we know it's there?
Because it exerts a gravitational force on galaxies and stars and galaxies.
And we can measure how much of them there is by looking at stars,
galaxies,
and clusters of galaxies and inferring the mass of them by,
by observing the orbits of things around the of justice we did with black holes
just as we did with planets.
This is a fairly straight forward,
uh,
astronomical technique.
All rest of it.
Okay.
This region here is dark energy,
which not only can we not detect directly,
but it has a physical effect unlike anything else we know anything about at all.
Namely,
it pushes out.
It's a,
it's a purely repulsive force of some time.
Uh,
and uh,
and it,
uh,
and that purely were false of force,
provides three quarters of the mass energy of the earth.
Well,
that's bad.
Uh,
cause we have even less idea.
Oh,
and I should say,
so we've been counting up frontiers and controversies with time.
This is frontiers and controversies in 2007.
What the heck is going on with this pie chart?
What's this?
What's this and why?
That's what we need to find out.
Uh,
now,
oddly enough,
it turns out Einstein predicted this.
Einstein was a genius.
Only he then retracted it and decided it was the greatest mistake you'd ever
made.
Uh,
and then it because he said it was a great mistake.
Everybody ignored it for 70 years until we discovered the dark energy.
And then somebody said,
oh,
you know,
Einstein told us about this already a,
and here's how,
why he did it.
Uh,
remember,
uh,
Einstein,
wanted,
uh,
a static universe.
This is before,
uh,
this is before Hubble discovered that the universe was expanding.
Its all.
Einstein was looking at the implications of his equations of general relativity.
And he thought it would be nice if the universe was static.
And the problem is there's all this matter in the universe,
so it attracts itself.
So it can't be static because if you try and hold it in one place,
it'll fall down.
It has to either be expanding up or expanding down just like the pen is either
going up or going down.
So,
uh,
but that's bad spot Einstein,
because it ought to be static.
So he invented a,
an additional term for his equation,
additional term,
which he wrote down as a capitol lambda and called the cosmological constant.
Yeah.
And this had a,
generated a repulsive force that would balance
gravity and lead to a static universe.
And it was allowed in the equations.
It fit fine into the equations.
There was no problem there.
Those of you who have done calculus,
um,
this shows up as a constant of integration.
So it can be any,
any value you like,
um,
if you don't know calculus,
ignore that last sentence.
Uh,
okay.
and so he invented this repulsive force,
this cosmological constant to balance grab gravity so that you could have a
static universe.
Then Hubble discovered that the universe isn't static,
discovers expansion.
And Einstein says,
damn,
I could have predicted that and then I would have been famous,
you know?
Uh,
so Einstein says,
uh,
Lambda was my biggest mistake
because if he hadn't been so insistent that the universe needed to turn out to
be static,
he could have said,
your doll,
my equations predicted university.
There has to be expanding or contracting.
It has to be moving around.
And then Hubble would have verified Einstein's prediction and Einstein might've
won the Nobel prize or something.
Uh,
so lambda was my biggest mistake,
except it turns out that it might be true.
Uh,
so this is one of those fables,
right?
Uh,
the fable of Einstein's,
uh,
biggest
a mistake,
uh,
and the moral is
interesting ideas,
uh,
can turn up in a different context and turn out to be even more important than
you thought they were,
who turn up in other
contexts.
So for 70 years,
you know,
the idea of this,
this lamb determined this cosmological constant was kind of buried in the
textbooks.
It would be,
you know,
problem 53 at the end of chapter seven,
supposing there is a cosmological constant,
then what would happen?
Uh,
and uh,
uh,
and generations of Grad students,
you know,
thought about this for 15 minutes and then forgot.
Uh,
and then all of a sudden,
uh,
it turns out to be,
an explanation for this very mysterious,
uh,
um,
a force.
Now this,
just because you stick it in an equation doesn't tell you what it is.
So what might it be?
The particle physicist,
it turns out,
have a little bit of an explanation for this called the vacuum energy.
I'll talk more about that later.
Never mind what it is.
I just wanted to point out that if you calculate what the vacuum energy is,
what you discover is that Omeka associated with this lambda is equal to 10 to
the hundred and 20.
That's a particle physics calculation.
Uh,
the observed Omega is equal to about three quarters.
Okay?
So this is the wrong guest calculation in the history of science.
Uh,
it's off by 120 orders of bag that you're nit fact,
it would be very bad if this was true because if there was that much repulsive
energy,
no galaxies would have formed.
No,
uh,
planets would have formed.
We wouldn't be here.
We,
all our stuff would have been sprayed out into the far reaches of the universe.
Uh,
so we knew already that that couldn't really be true.
and so what the particle physicist said was,
you know,
obviously this can't be true.
Salt must somehow cancel out,
so it must be zero.
Uh,
because otherwise we have this embarrassing problem,
which we know can't be true.
The fact that it,
it small but not zero is completely mysterious.
Uh,
and,
uh,
that's where we'll start next time.